around the world renewable energy use is
on the rise
and these alternative energy sources
could hold the key to combating climate
change
[Music]
what is renewable energy
renewable energy is generated from
sources that naturally replenish
themselves and never run out
the most common sources are solar wind
hydro geothermal and biomass
over 80 percent of the total energy
consumed by humans is derived from
fossil fuels
however renewables are the fastest
growing source of energy in the world
renewable energy has many benefits
first it can combat climate change
because it creates no direct greenhouse
gas emissions the only emissions that
they produce are indirect meaning those
that result from manufacturing parts
installation operation and maintenance
but even those are minimal
second
renewable energy can decrease pollution
and therefore reduce threats to our
health
wind solar and hydroelectric systems
create no air pollution emissions
and geothermal and biomass energy
systems emissions are much lower than
non-renewable energy sources
third
renewable energy is a reliable source of
power
because renewable energy sources are
well renewable they will never run out
once built renewable facilities cost
very little to operate and the fuel is
often free
as a result renewable energy prices tend
to be stable over time
while renewable energy has many
advantages it is not without downsides
it is difficult for renewable energy
sources to generate power on the same
large scale as fossil fuels
building wind farms and dams can disrupt
wildlife and migration patterns and lead
to ecological destruction
both solar and wind energy are
intermittent they only generate power
while the sun is shining or while the
wind is blowing
batteries can store excess energy for
later use however they are often costly
while renewable energy presents some
challenges it also offers an
environmentally friendly alternative to
the greenhouse gas emissions and
pollution of fossil fuels
and as advances in technology make
renewable energy more accessible
affordable and efficient
and end to climate change could be
within our reach
[Music]
you